today on the male wall show chaos and
uncertainty around the election
this is the inevitable result of a
confused and haphazard voting system
combined with a total lack of trust in
the media and our institutions
the media now scolds americans who
question the election results
but it's their own fault for giving us
so many reasons to doubt everything they
tell us also
five headlines including moves all
across the country to legalize
drugs is it time for the gop to make
marijuana legalization part of its
platform and in our daily cancellation
i will cancel national geographic for
speculating
that prehistoric people 9 000 years ago
may have been proponents of
left-wing gender theory all of that and
much more coming up but
let's begin here with something very
simple here's my radical position okay
all of the legal and valid votes should
be counted
and we should make sure that they're
counted correctly
that's it that's my whole position it
should be uncontroversial
bipartisan but apparently it's not
apparently
it's an extreme right-wing talking point
to advocate for careful
and correct tabulation of the results
somehow in fact
it undermines the legitimacy of our
election it undermines the legitimacy of
our election
to make sure that the election is
legitimate this is what we're being told
and we're being told this again by the
same people who for years called trump
an illegitimate president with no
evidence or
reason for that claim so here's the
here's the reality even without
any indication of malfeasance even if
there were
no hints of possible subterfuge i would
still be saying that there should be
recounts in audits for three rather
important reasons number one
it's an extremely close election with
the results in some states coming down
to less than one percentage
point separation between the candidates
which puts it in the range where
recounts can be done already
if only a comparatively few votes
determine the outcome of a hotly
contested election
there is reason to go back and make sure
everything was done right
very simple number two we have never
seen so many ballots mailed in
and sent early this is an entirely new
world we're in now
elections have never been done like this
they shouldn't be done like this now
it's obviously led to confusion already
there have been problems at a minimum
and that's just from what we know
massive delays ballots
seeming to appear out of nowhere just
this morning it was announced that
georgia has
50 to 60 000 uncounted ballots which was
quote more than initially thought we
need to understand what's happening here
it would be insane to just take the
results as their first reported
when the states have to keep
backtracking and they don't seem to know
what they're doing as they do it
number three as discussed yesterday
there is a widespread belief that donald
trump is a real life
fascist dictator who has effectively
murdered hundreds of thousands of
americans
and wants to murder thousands more this
is false obviously ridiculous but
it's what people believe it's what
they've been told which creates an
enormous perhaps
overwhelming incentive to cheat and
it's another reason to go back and check
again
these are the reasons again for for
better oversight and double checking
that would stand
even if you didn't have indications of
possible fraud happening
but we do have those indications on top
of everything else for example they
taped up the windows in michigan
where people were counting ballots taped
up the window so that nobody could look
in and see
what's the reason for that is there a
good reason is there a is there a
you know is there an honest reason in
north carolina they're now saying that
they're not going to update their total
vote count until next week
november 12th in pennsylvania they're
allowing ballots to be counted
even if they don't arrive until three
days after the election and even if
they're not clearly postmarked
for before the deadline okay
they will count ballots that could have
been mailed after the election they will
that's true
there is reason to be suspicious about
some of this but this stuff especially
that last point about pennsylvania
and especially because pennsylvania
officials are in the can for biden and
they're not hiding it the pennsylvania
attorney general announced a day before
the election that biden would win
the secretary of state in pennsylvania
who's in charge of the vote count
said on twitter a couple years ago that
quote using the title president before
the word trump really demeans the office
of the presidency
this is an extremely partisan person who
hates trump
so much that to simply call him
president demeans the office in her mind
is there at least reason to suspect that
maybe those late ballots are being
allowed
and the rules are being loosened and
changed at the last minute because these
people who hate trump
hate trump and want him gone is there
reason to
maybe possibly consider that yes there
is to put it
very mildly listen this is what it comes
down to we are
uh as americans in a position where
we are being asked and told to trust
what we're told right but trust what and
who
well trust information disseminated by
hyper-partisan officials
through the mouthpiece of a
hyper-partisan media
and we're told that it's our fault if we
don't trust them
we're conspiracy theorists that we
somehow are the ones
undermining the integrity and legitimacy
of our system no
it isn't us you damned liars you you
snakes it is not us
it's you these people by these people i
refer to the whole democrat
media complex the ones who were being
asked
to trust right now these people have
spent years openly
lying this goes way back before trump
but has been significantly worse more
obvious more pronounced
more relentless under trump they said
trump was a russian spy they ran
they ran with every ridiculous
unverified claim they could
they tried to take down kavanaugh by
calling him a serial gang rapist
they say even now that amy coney barrett
is an illegitimate supreme court justice
nancy pelosi said that a few days ago no
basis for that no justification
it's a straight out lie insidious
reprehensible
immoral told for the sake of gaining
power
like all the other lies they tell and
this is just in the political realm the
democrat media complex
has also encouraged and defended and
justified rioting in the streets pouring
fuel on the fire literally continuously
by blowing every out of context police
shooting wildly out of proportion
telling us that there's a conspiracy of
racist cops out hunting and killing
black men
they do this they know it's not true
they know the damage it causes
they know that it's getting people
killed but they do it anyway because
it's about power
ends justify the means and now they have
the audacity
to demand trust and the audacity to act
offended and hurt
if we suggest that maybe these people
would cheat
maybe these people who have been
cheating already
would continue cheating on election day
no
go to hell don't give me that you did
this you deserve it this is your fault
we don't trust you we never will we need
evidence we need receipts
your word is nothing your word is trash
you have trashed it you have made this
country what it is now
you have planted these seeds and now you
will reap them
and that's just how it's going to be
blame yourself
it's all your fault let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
well you know with all the craziness
happening in the world right now maybe
it
makes you start thinking about you know
you have to be prepared for
uh anything that might happen it's all
it's i i think we should be thinking in
terms of getting prepared
and um one thing that you should do to
be prepared is to have
life insurance and the problem is that
you know shopping for life insurance can
seem like a daunting task it seems like
the kind of thing
you know you don't know where to start
where to go but um if you've got loved
ones then it's really important that you
do it
and that's why policy genius is around
and that's why they make it very easy to
do they combine a cutting-edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts
to save you time and money and just
because it's cutting edge doesn't mean
it's difficult to do
right now you could save 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade those
savings really start to add up you can
save a lot of money so
head to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price policy genius will
compare policies starting as
at as little as one dollar a day you
might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam
you know but you got to go to policy
genius and figure that out so
once you apply the pulse of genius will
handle team will handle all the red tape
all the
paperwork and everything they're going
to take care of that all you got to do
is go there and apply
very very easy so if you need life
insurance head to policygenius.com right
now to get started
you can save 50 or more by comparing
quotes
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's
important to get it right all right um
so reading from the hill it says
stung by their party's uh dispiriting
showing at the polls
on tuesday two moderate house democrats
say they and other centres are privately
discussing a plan that was unthinkable
just 24 hours earlier
throwing their support behind a
challenger to speaker nancy pelosi the
two democrats told the hill on wednesday
that they were reaching out to their
colleagues about backing one of pelosi's
top lieutenants
house democratic caucus chairman hakeem
jeffries for speaker in the house
congress
he's the only one prepared and
positioned to be speaker said one of the
democratic lawmakers he bridges
moderates and progresses better than
anybody
and most importantly he's not pelosi
although
apparently jeffrey shot down the idea
and said he's focused on on you know on
keeping his current spot and of course
he has to say that
here's and i've been reading more about
this and you you
we're seeing this more and more that
while democrats need to moderate a
little bit they need to start elevating
the centrists and moderates in their
party
the problem is that and this is
this is a pretty big logistical problem
there are no centrists and moderates in
the democrat party
to elevate um i mean we we might be down
to like in the entire democrat party
across the entire country
there might be literally a hand well not
literally a handful uh there might be
you know a two or three or four or five
i mean it's
it's there are very very few of them
because this is what the democrat party
has become is even
the so-called anytime you hear that
someone is a a moderate democrat
well ask them do they believe in any
restrictions for abortions whatsoever
do they believe in that it's okay to
kill infants up into the moment of birth
because you'll find even the moderate
ones hold that view which is an extreme
view
do they believe in pregnant men do they
think that men can get pregnant
even the moderate ones hold that view
these are
radical extreme viewpoints that even the
so-called moderate democrats
subscribe to and that's going to be a
problem for the democratic party if they
want to moderate
they're always moderating in relation
to how far left they've gone
so what is centrist and moderate in the
modern democrat party
would have been wildly extreme left-wing
25-30 years ago
um number two election protests all
across the country
and here's how it went in new york watch
you're all oh
as you can see there she spits in the
officer's face uh is arrested
it's quite satisfying at least to see
her taken down and arrested hopefully
that disgusting trashy woman will be
locked in a cage for a long time you
know spitting on a police officer
already a crime doing it during a
pandemic should be even more of a crime
uh you know the charger is a biological
terrorist thrower in gitmo i'd be fine
with that
this is we talked about yesterday
feminism and the effect it has on women
well you know when you see videos like
this here you go crass
vulgar gross
uh the obliteration of anything that is
truly feminine
that's that's what you get from feminism
number three uh hilarious stuff here the
daily wire reports that bloomberg
spent 100 million dollars in florida
well florida ohio and texas
spent 100 million dollars total in all
those states for joe biden
and all of those states went to trump
handily comfortably
um this after the guy blew through like
a billion dollars
on his own campaign a campaign that
lasted about 17 seconds
or so that's how much he's wasted it
it really is amazing have we ever seen
anything have we ever seen money wasted
like this
so quickly with nothing to show for it
well i guess we see it all the time with
our government they blow through
trillions with nothing to show for it
but
on a private level on a private scale
have we seen it i don't know
uh just a billion 1.1 billion up in
flames
even worse than up in flames it would
have been better for him to literally
burn it because then at least he'd have
the ashes that he could
compost and use it to grow tomatoes and
cucumbers get a nice salad out of the
deal kind of an expensive salad but
um for that he doesn't have a salad for
this
nothing at all this was all for nothing
but i think that's great
and uh quite hilarious i mean he's the
kind of guy that you enjoy seeing
humiliated might not be the most
charitable thing to say but
that's where i'm at right now um and uh
in other election news with a lot of
uncertainty about which candidates
americans chose it does seem certain
that
americans chose something else uh drugs
we don't know which candidate they
prefer but um it does seem like
americans are big fans of drugs here's
uh here's the vox article it says in
every state where a ballot measure asked
americans to reconsider the drug war
voters sided with reformers in arizona
montana new jersey and south dakota
voters legalize marijuana for
recreational purposes
in mississippi and south dakota separate
from the full legalization measure
voters legalize medical marijuana in
oregon
voters decriminalized but not legalized
all drugs this is a decriminalization of
all drugs
including cocaine and heroin actually
the only thing that surprises me there
is that that hadn't already happened
you mean that up until now heroin and
cocaine was was technically criminalized
in oregon
you never know it when you look at the
footage out of portland also in oregon
voters legalize the use of a psychedelic
drug found in magic mushrooms for
supervised therapeutic uses in
washington dc voters in effect
decriminalize psychedelic plants
following the lead of several other
cities and with its vote oregon became
the first state in the u.s
in modern times to decriminalize all
drugs
and marijuana is now legalized in 15
states and d.c
although d.c still allows doesn't allow
sale of
marijuana so it's legal but you can't
sell it that makes a lot of sense
so this is uh with with everything else
happening
i i think this isn't getting a whole lot
of attention but
this is a pretty significant shift
i mean you want to talk about the way
things have shifted you go back 20 or 25
years
you know marijuana was illegal i think
everywhere
and but but also i think if you look at
the opinion polls
almost everyone would be against all
forms of of drug legalization
and now it's a totally mainstream view
and the thing is
yeah i don't feel i've never felt
especially strong about this
a couple of lines i will draw i think
pretty easily
i i think to legalize or decriminalize
hard drugs like heroin
it's crazy um i also but i also think on
the other end of it
legalizing medicinal marijuana obviously
i mean the whole idea that the situation
that's been in many states for so long
where you know you weren't allowed to
use medicinal marijuana if you had
chronic pain or terminal cancer uh
something like that you couldn't use
medicinal marijuana
you could use medicinal heroin and you
you you could go get oxycontin or
something
extremely addictive lots of people
get addicted to it lots of people
overdose on it so that's okay but not
medicinal marijuana which is much less
addictive
much safer some would say more effective
that never made any sense so seems to me
two obvious things two obvious lines you
could draw
would seem to me no
heroin should not be legal should be
criminalized uh medicinal marijuana
should be legalized and then
in the middle you know where do you go
there and i've kind of i've kind of gone
back and forth on it but i think
um i
th really and i would admit this that
i i still can't fully bring myself on
board with the idea of
legalizing marijuana but it's more just
on a visceral level i don't have a great
argument against it
because any any argument and i would i i
admit this
any argument i would make against
legalizing marijuana
would apply you know the social harm
and all that sort of thing would apply
just as well to
alcohol if not more so and yet i
certainly am not in favor of alcohol
prohibition
and i think that's the effective
argument that pro-marijuana legalization
people have always made which is
look if you're making these arguments
against marijuana then why isn't
everything prohibited it doesn't make
you're drawing a very arbitrary line
here and it seems like you're just doing
it on a visceral level
because it's something that you smoke
and uh you know and you just don't like
it
and so you're okay you don't want that
but you're okay with uh with people
going and buying
hard liquor at the liquor store and i
think that's basically true so i kind of
even though i can't i can't quite
emotionally bring myself there um
i i think that the pro-legalization
people have
intellectually they have the uh
they have the intellectual arguments on
their side i would say
even though they're a bunch of potheads
uh so this is probably something that
the you know the republican party should
think about
getting behind i mean it's a it's a it's
probably the right
view and it's popular view
and uh it's all about being popular i
suppose all right let's go to our
daily cancellation today for our daily
cancellation if i may dare to talk about
something other than the election for a
few minutes
i'm afraid i have to cancel national
geographic
really i could cancel national
geographic just for their decision
several years ago to change the name of
their tv channel to nat
geo yes i have to go by nat geo because
apparently it's too difficult and
confusing for people
people to say national geographic no
words above two syllables are allowed
anymore in society
you especially can't combine two words
of three syllables or
or more that that scares people you
can't do that and this has been the
trajectory of human language for a long
time
words become shorter and simpler
eventually getting replaced with
indecipherable grunting so in 10 years
nat geo will be called nat
and its top-rated show will be a
documentary series about how different
types of monkeys
sound when they fart which come to think
of it i would actually watch
but in any case the reason we're
canceling national geographic today
is for an article just published on its
website written by maya
wajas with the title prehistoric female
hunter discovery up ends
gender role assumptions now you already
know
it's gonna be bad but trust me it's way
way worse than you think so let's read a
little bit here
um before we uh really get to the
stupidity fireworks at the end but
uh it says randall haas an archaeologist
at university of california davis
recalls the moment in 2018 when his team
of researchers gathered around the
excavated burial of an individual lane
tourist in the andes mountain of peru
some 9 000 years ago along with the
bones of what appeared to be a human
adult was an impressive and extensive
kit of stone tools an ancient hunter
would need to take down big game
uh from engaging the hunt to preparing
the hype
it said this quoting now from haas says
he must have been a really great hunter
a really important person in society
haas says that's what he and his team
were thinking at the time
but further analysis reveals a prize the
remains found alongside the toolkit were
from a biological female
when archaeologists excavated the burial
they found a colorful array of 24 stone
twos stone
tools among them projectile points for
taking down a large mammal
hefty rocks likely for cracking bones or
stripping hides
small rounded stony bits for scraping
fat from pelts
tiny flakes with extra sharp edges that
could have chopped the meat
and nodules of red uh of uh that could
help preserve the hide
scattered around the site were fragments
of the bones of animals including
ancient llama relatives and deer
back in the lab close inspection of the
bone suggested the physiology of a
biological woman to confirm
they analyze the protein that forms
tooth enamel enamel and
is linked to sex okay now
we haven't gotten to the cancelable part
here but
maybe you can guess what's coming there
so i will say you know i'm not an
archaeologist
it seems to me that mostly what they
found are tools to prepare the meat
often the person preparing the meat is
not the person who killed it
it doesn't necessarily mean this is a
hunter also just because someone was
buried with a tool kit
that doesn't mean they use they use the
toolkit you know it could be some kind
of symbolic thing part of a religious
ritual
which the article does acknowledge later
on uh and also you know
these are rocks we're talking about i
mean they could have been used for
anything
but whatever fine let's say that this
was a this was a badass
independent woman of the year 7000 bc
who didn't need no man
i'm okay with that no problem but then
here comes the idiocy avalanche okay
the article says quote importantly the
team cannot know
the individual's gender identity but
rather only biological sex
which like gender doesn't always exist
on a binary in other words
they can't say whether the individual
lived their life 9 000 years ago in a
way that would identify them
within their society as a woman this is
not parody folks
yes national geographic is really
suggesting that the prehistoric woman
may have been non-binary and yeah i
guess we don't know
maybe she was a genderqueer non-binary
bisexual
maybe she had short cropped hair spent
her friday nights performing feminist
slam poetry at her local coffee shop
maybe she would go around to the other
huts and explain to the other
prehistoric people
in her clan that you know they need to
break free from their heteronormative
thinking and examine their cis privilege
maybe she played the keyboard in an
experimental indie rock band
called the anachronisms i mean i can't
disprove
any of that it's all technically
possible but it's also all a bunch of
arbitrary
insane nonsensical speculation
as we have talked about on the show um
the the whole idea of gender identity as
distinct from biological sex
was invented in the 1950s by an insane
creep
named john money so i feel fairly
confident in assuming that a concept
invented
out of whole cloth 70 years ago did not
exist
9 000 years ago in fact history shows
that for the entirety of human
civilization
until very recently everyone thought
that men were men women were women
and all societies everywhere had ideas
about the roles that men and women
should play
in society those ideas weren't always
the same but there was always a
recognition
of the difference and an acknowledgement
that the difference matters
we in modern times are the only ones so
dumb
as to be confused about this prehistoric
people
weren't advanced enough to be as stupid
as us
and i i can imagine prehistoric people
looking looking on from the great beyond
hearing about this national geographic
article and saying whoa hey man
don't drag us into this we know what men
and women are okay so speak for
yourselves here
all right also notice how natural
geographic and alleged scientific
publication
says that sex not just gender sex is not
on a binary
and to support this wild claim
it gives us a link to a world health
organization article and that article
says
quote humans are born with 46
chromosomes
in 23 pairs the x and y chromosomes
determine a person's sex
most women are 46 xx and most men are 46
x
research suggests however that in a few
births per thousand some individuals
will be born with a single sex
chromosome
45x or 45y and some with three or more
sex chromosomes
in addition some males are born 46xx due
to the translocation of a tiny section
of the sex determining region of the y
chromosome
similarly some females are also bored 46
xy due to the mutations in the y
chromosome clearly there are not only
females who are xx and males who are xy
but rather there is a range of
chromosomes
or rather chromosome complements hormone
imbalances
and phonetic variations that determine
sex okay
that's what the world health
organization says a couple things there
first even if i were to accept that
these
few per thousand cases represent a
breakdown of the sex binary
and that the people who fall into this
tiny fraction of the population are
neither men nor women
or are some combination of the two that
still wouldn't at all
justify or legitimize the leftist claims
about gender because
they say that biological men fully
biological men xy chromosomes no
no abnormalities can be women that's
their claim
that claim is not proven or at all
advanced by the existence of these
abnormalities but second note how this
is phrased
it says some males are born 46xx due to
the translocation of a tiny section of
the chromosome
similarly some females are also born 46
ex-wife
so that's the phrasing so that they're
they're
they're calling them males and females
that's that's what the who is saying
they're still males or females according
to the world health organization
what we're talking about are males and
females who suffer from rare mutations
but these are still males or females a
male with a mutation
is a male with a mutation just like a
person born with one arm is not a whole
new species or type of human
it's just someone who should have had
two arms but doesn't
nothing confusing or particularly
strange is happening here even if it is
rare
so this from national geographic excuse
me nat geo
is scientifically false absurd laughable
embarrassing and it makes me think they
really should just stick with
farting monkeys science just
isn't their bag anymore and that's why
they are canceled
good good to get that in little little
non-election cancellation
still i still make time you know you got
you got to make time for the
cancellations even when there's so much
else going on in the world
so glad we could do that that's going to
do it for us today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
lots of irregularities in pennsylvania
michigan wisconsin arizona
accusations of unprecedented fraud some
accusations of precedented fraud
we will go through all of the claims
check it out on the michael knowles show